Denis un peu pour le groupe de l'Union
centriste
[Applaudissements]
vous avez la parole
monsieur le Président Madame la première
ministre messieurs les ministres mes
chers collègues avant que d'évoquer la
politique énergétique de la France
il nous faut établir ce que nous sommes
en droit d'attendre d'un système
énergétique
premièrement de la sécurité et j'entends
derrière ce concept sécurité
d'approvisionnement afin d'éviter
d'élastage rationnement et blackout la
deuxième exigence c'est le maintien de
notre souveraineté notre système
énergétique doit dépendre le moins
possible de puissance étrangères surtout
quand ces dernières sont potentiellement
instables ou hostiles troisièmement pour
atténuer le changement climatique en
cours notre système énergétique doit
tendre vers la neutralité carbone
à l'heure actuelle forcer de constater
qu'il présente malheureusement des
lacunes sur les trois tableaux la plus
visible en ce moment concerne
l'insécurité d'approvisionnement avec le
spectre d'une pénurie d'énergie qui
ressurgit pour l'électricité cela tient
notamment au vieillissement des
centrales nucléaires quant au gaz il
fait désormais défaut aux Européens du
fait de la guerre à l'Ukraine même si la
France en souffre moins que nombre de
ses voisins
ces déficiences nous rendent par
conséquent dépendant de l'étranger qu'il
s'agisse de notre voisin allemand pour
l'électricité en période de pointe ou
bien de la Norvège éducateur pour le gaz
enfin notre mix énergétique n'est pas
assez décarbonée car plus de 60% de nos
besoins énergétiques sont encore
satisfaits par du gaz et du pétrole
cela il est vrai que nous faisons mieux
que bien d'autres pays mais c'est encore
largement incompatible avec les
objectifs fixés par la corde de Paris
sur le clim il nous faut donc réformer
notre système énergétique à la fois pour
répondre aux enjeux immédiats et pour
garantir les générations futures à court
terme le gouvernement semble avoir bien
saisi les enjeux depuis plusieurs mois
il était effectivement nécessaire de
sécuriser l'approvisionnement en gaz de
notre pays en trouvant de nouveaux
fournisseurs ce qui a permis de remplir
nos stocks au maximum avant l'hiver à
moyen terme il faudrait toutefois
envisager de produire ce gaz sur le sol
national par exemple avec la
méthanisation
de même il fallait organiser la sobriété
pour réduire les tensions sur notre
système électrique c'est l'intérêt du
plan dévoilé jeudi dernier rappelant
quand la matière les efforts doivent
concernés autant l'État et les
entreprises que les particuliers et les
collectivités territoriales enfin je
salue madame la ministre votre
mobilisation constante et celle de votre
gouvernement
auprès de la Commission européenne pour
qu'elle propose des solutions
collectives aux États membres c'est à ce
niveau que les actions seront le plus
efficaces en matière énergétique car
c'est à l'Union européenne de régler le
problème central posé par cette crise
celui de la formation du prix de
l'électricité ce dernier correspond au
coût marginal du dernier opérateur
connecté au réseau or aujourd'hui ce
dernier opérateur ce sont les centrales
à gaz dans le coup de production tire
l'ensemble des prix vers le haut aussi
faut-il découpler au plus vite le prix
de l'électricité de celui du gaz pour ce
faire devoir existe soit par le haut
soit par le bas par le haut c'est à dire
en créant un grand service européen de
l'énergie publique et monopolistique
hélas cela relève actuellement de
l'utopie nous n'arrivons déjà pas à nous
mettre d'accord sur la taxonomie
l'autre voix la plus réaliste est une
sortie par le bas c'est à dire une forme
de
renationalisation du système c'est ce
qu'on fait l'Espagne et le Portugal avec
l'aval de la Commission européenne ils
ont ainsi le droit du rang 1 an de
déconnecter le prix du gaz de celui de
l'électricité de fait cela leur réussite
tandis que fin août le prix du
mégawatt-heure était de 660 euros en
France et en Allemagne il n'était que de
240 euros en Espagne et au Portugal
cette dérogation leur a été accordée
pour deux raisons ils sont très peu
interconnectés avec le reste de l'Europe
et ils ont une électricité très
décarbonée
symétriquement cela signifie que l'on
doit envisager la solution
ibérique pour les pays européens dans
l'électricité est déjà largement
décarbonée comme la France la situation
actuelle ne peut en effet plus duré une
fois nos centrales remises un ordre de
marche notre situation énergétique
serait meilleure en faisant cavalier
seul avec le monopole d'EDF plutôt que
dans le marché de l'électricité
communautaire dans le même ordre d'idée
l'ouverture du marché de l'énergie n'a
pas donné des résultats satisfaisants
revenir dessus nous permettrait de
supprimer cette absurdité que la reine
ce dernier a été une belle aubaine pour
des opérateurs qui se sont comportés
comme de simples négociants
engrangeant des profits sur l'argent du
contribuable investi dans centrale il
est temps désormais d'arrêter de
considérer l'énergie comme une simple
marchandise et la prendre pour ce
qu'elle est réellement un bien public de
première nécessité à ce titre il
convient de s'interroger sur la
pertinence d'un éventuel retour au tarif
réglementé de vente de l'électricité et
même du gaz à plus long terme c'est
d'une vision stratégique dont nous avons
besoin tel que celles présentées par le
Président de la République dans son
discours de Belfort en février dernier
cette stratégie repose sur le triptyque
sobriété nucléaires et renouvelable nous
ne pouvons qui souscrire mais lorsque
l'on regarde de plus en détail ce beau
tableau les choses se compliquent
singulièrement premièrement les
projections relatives à la qui était
nous semble irréaliste certes nous
pouvons renforcer nos efforts sur de
nombreux plans tels que l'isolation des
bâtiments ou l'autoconsommation mais 40%
de besoins énergétiques en moins en
200040 alors que nous serons un peu plus
nombreux et 20% plus riches si la
croissance moyenne n'est que de 1% d'ici
à cette date qui petit croire c'est
pourtant sur une telle anticipation que
repose la stratégie nationale Bach
carbone et tous les scénarios de RTE
en adoptant des hypothèses plus
réalistes ce sera déjà une très belle
performance d'arriver simplement à
maintenir et non augmenter nos besoins
énergétiques d'ici à 2040 mais dans ce
cas de figure ce n'est pas 60%
d'électricité en plus qu'il nous faudra
produire au tournant du siècle mais le
double ou le triple c'est bien pourquoi
les annonces faites jusqu'ici en matière
de nucléaire même si elles vont
incontestablement dans le bon sens nous
semble bien trop insuffisante à Belfort
le président de la République a déclaré
qu'aucun réacteur un état de produire ne
doit être fermé mais le plan de
fermeture de 12 réacteurs d'ici à 2035
est toujours en vigueur va t-il enfin
être officiellement abandonné dans
l'affirmative va-t-on prolonger nos
réacteurs au maximum c'est une question
clé car maintenant de PR a construire en
dépend de plus aucun plan de
développement de SMS n'a été annoncé
alors que le petit nucléaire semble une
solution d'avenir prometteuse enfin la
recherche est l'innovation dans le
nouveau nucléaire semblent relancer mais
à quelle fin précisément fermeture du
cycle du combustible réacteur de 4e
génération au thorion il faut un plan et
des objectifs enfin pour ce qui est des
renouvelables je ne veux pas ici
empiéter sur les débats qui seront les
nôtres lors de l'examen du projet de loi
e NR mais je peux déjà dire que le
groupe de l'Union centriste plaidera en
faveur de l'essor de la grille voltaïsme
de la géothermie et de la biomasse plus
globalement chacun des trois volets du
plan français va se heurter un grave
problème de ressources humaines il faut
former dès maintenant de vrais
professionnels du nucléaire des réseaux
très intelligent de l'isolation des
bâtiments et des eénères avons-nous un
plan de formation digne de ce nom pour
faire face à ses besoins si oui il nous
faudra le connaître les événements
autant que le sens de l'histoire nous
invite à un Big Bang énergétique alors
montrons-nous à la hauteur de ce
rendez-vous je vous remercie merci
chers collègues
[Applaudissements]